Je sais pas si vous avez remarquer sur Snapchat,
à chaque...
Ah ça ??
Oui, j'ai déménagé !
C'est pas vrai.
En fait, c'est un décor, autour il n'y a absolument rien.
Les lampes ne marchent même pas.
OK, celle-ci elle marche.
Pour les vieux qui regardent cette vidéo : Snapchat, qu'est-ce que c'est ?
C'est une application qui permet d'envoyer des messages,
des photos, des vidéos qui dure que quelques secondes.
Même si vous êtes vieux, vous pouvez la télécharger.
Il suffit de taper "Snapchat".
"Snapchat", et c'est bon.
La technique anti-vieux.
C'est un peu déroutant Snapchat au début.
Pourquoi envoyer une photo qui sera supprimer ensuite ?
La photographie, c'est un art, c'est le 8e art,
ça raconte quelque chose.
c'est noble !
Et voilà !
Je suis fier de vous presenter mon chef d'oeuvre.
Ca vous a plu ?
Vous voulez qu'on en parle ?
Ce qui est marrant sur Snapchat,
il y a souvent une différence entre le snap que
tu envoies a quelqu'un du même sexe, genre ton pote.
Et le snap que t'envoies, à quelqu'un de sexe opposé.
Genre une meuf que tu veux pécho.
C'est bizarre ce comportement sur Snapchat.
On n'est pas comme ça dans la vraie vie.
On aime tous recevoir un snap un petit peu mignon,
voire un peu coquin.
Même uniquement coquin, ça suffit.
Quand un pote en reçoit à côté de toi,
t'as envie de voir !
Comment elle est bonne la meuf !
Trop tard, désolé.
Allez, salut !
Oh, la meuf !
Je vais faire comme les 5 tweets à éviter sur Twitter
Je vous livre mes 5 trucs qui m'énervent sur Snapchat :
5) Le snap de l'artiste peintre.
Je reçois parfois des snaps avec des dessins de ouf !
Le mec a passé des heures et quand je compare avec les miens,
je me sens totalement nul.
Tranquillement, le mec, avec son doigt, est plus doué
que toi avec toute la papeterie de la planète.
Alors quand je reçois ça,
je ne réponds pas.
Comme ça, le mec, il pète un câble.
IL M'A FALLU 3 HEURES POUR CE SNAP,
TU PEUX ME REPONDRE AU MOINS !!!
Oui, je suis un connard.
4) Tu peux choisir la durée de ton snap,
je comprends pas ceux qui laissent la durée maximale
pour un snap qui n'a aucun intérêt.
Pourquoi ton chat mérite 10 secondes,
il peut se passer pleins de trucs en 10 secondes !
Vous êtes en état d'arrestation.
Vous devez vous tromper !
Je viens de vous sauver la vie.
Merci beaucoup.
Oh, regardez !
Allo maman ?
Allo.
Quoi ??
En fait, je suis ta mère... en fait j'ai fait un changement de sexe...
Papa ?! Euh maman !
3) On peut savoir qui a fait un screenshot de ton snap.
Ça, c'est une fonctionnalité super intéressante et
il y a des gens qui font des screenshots de tout ce que tu fais.
A quoi ça te sers, sérieux ?!
Je collectionne des photos des gens,
je les imprime et je les mets dans ma bouche...
2) Alors il y a ceux qui font des snaps inutiles de 10 secondes
Et à l'inverse il y a ceux qui font des snaps d'une seconde
T'as le temps de voir quoi exactement en une seconde ?
Tu t'es cru dans un jeu de mémorisation, c'est ça ?
Heureusement que les snaps d'une seconde sont souvent...
des photos de bite.
C'est pour ça que je fais des screenshots.
1) Peut-être le truc qui m'enerve le plus sur Snapchat,
c'est quand je reçois une vidéo courte
mais que je suis en silencieux.
(inaudible)
J'espère que c'était pas intéressant.
Je critique pas mal Snapchat mais
c'est quand même mortel.
Parfois, je reçois des snaps mémorables de mes potes.
On se tape des barres de ouf.
D'ailleurs, vous pouvez m'ajouter sur Snap.
C'est CyprienVideo.
Tout simplement.
Bon par contre, comment parler de Snapchat
sans évoquer la plus grande phobie des utilisateurs de l'application
on a tous peur qu'un jour...
En fait, depuis le début,
on gardait toutes les photos.
D'ailleurs, à partir de maintenant,
elles sont disponibles sur Internet.
Allez, salut !
Abonne-toi !
Enfin, si tu as envie... tu fais comme tu veux.
J'ai dis ça comme ça.
Sous-titrage : TeamSubtitle.